hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it
gives the 20th of every and your change
into games but news today we've got
Kickstarter's xbox one remotes and
sexual identities oh my gamer X to the
convention that celebrates the LGBTQ
community is looking for funding for its
next event the organizers behind the con
have turned to Kickstarter to raise the
ten thousand dollar deposit they need to
reserve the Intercontinental Hotel in
San Francisco where the event will be
held currently they're well and truly
reach their goal thanks to just over 100
backers with 32 days to go apart from
celebrating diversity and inclusivity in
gaming the corn is also more than open
to people who don't identify as LGBTQ
the three-day event will feature a bunch
of panels and talks with devs including
bioware's david guetta and reddit
co-founder alexis ohanian if you would
like to attend to be sure to be over 18
years old and keep July 11 to 13 open in
your calendars carrying on with that
theme and der block your ears if you're
averse to the last of us dlc spoilers
Naughty Dog is defending the sexual
orientation of its characters in
response to have seen in DLC where le
kisses have female friend Riley the last
of us game director Bruce telly has said
a good character is a good character and
who cares what it implies about her
sexual identity also challenged with the
notion the triple-a games were played
almost exclusively by mail since
apparently forty percent of the audience
who cracked into the last of us was
female speaking about Ellie Naughty Dog
has said they went out of their way to
make her fiercely independent and
capable did you guys play The Last of Us
and what did you think of Ellie as of
today the xbox one now has a media
remote for all the times that it just
won't respond to xbox one watch TV I
blame the accent the media remote will
be landing in March and will cost you 25
bucks which is mostly drawing concern
that it might be a tad steep the little
remote will let you navigate to launch
and control
media apps you know like all remotes it
apparently also functions as an infrared
remote to control TV or AV receiver
volume and has a button to launch the
one guide TV functionality although
apparently the channel up and down
buttons will only work in the u.s.
within the TV app fortunately that
doesn't really matter since TV receiver
support is only available in the US the
main concern from you guys in the
comments seems to be puzzlement over why
the all-in-one media center of a console
didn't just come with a remote to start
with let me know if you'll be picking
one up and what do you think of the
price either in the comments down below
or you can do so on my Twitter where I'm
at jeffs McDonald that's all I got for
you today but tomorrow I've got my top 5
of the week if you missed any of this
weeks earlier episode so be sure to
check back then and I will see you soon